Good afternoon. Thank you for coming.
I should say this is all about Eli, but my name is Johan de Bono.
I work in London at the Institute of Cancer Research,
and it's been my privilege to know and work with Eli for some time.
But
I want to first of all say, I hope you're enjoying this amazing
AACR annual meeting. We are truly privileged to be here.
I should also say that there should be a QR code on the screen,
and can I please beg you to
scan that, because that's how you can ask questions later, unless you
want to come to the microphone.
So it is my great honor to be here to serve as chair
for the selection committee for this year's AACR Wang Ki
Hong Award for Outstanding Achievement in
Translational and Clinical Cancer Research.
The AACR established this award in memory of the late Dr.
Wang Ki Hong,
AACR past president and elected fellow of the AACR
Academy, to honor his extraordinary contributions to cancer prevention,
patient care, and cancer research during his long and brilliant career as a
physician-scientist. I met
Dr. Wang Ki Hong many years ago,
and it was really a privilege to spend time with him
at one of the mentoring meetings that AACR organized.
This award serves to recognize cancer researchers anywhere in the
world who have conducted highly meritorious
translational and clinical research.
My personal
on the right here.
So it's my great privilege and honor to introduce this year's
recipient, a physician scientist whose work has truly
advanced precision oncology,
arguably even created a new field of
computational cancer research, integrating cancer
genomics and computational biology.
So this 2026 recipient of this prestigious award is
Dr. Eli Van Allen, Chief of the Division of Population
Sciences at Dana-Farber Cancer Institute and Professor of
Medicine at Harvard Medical School.
Eli is a leader in clinical computational oncology, a field
he really helped to create and define.
At a time when very few physician scientists were
exploring the clinical applications of computational biology, and
I knew nothing about this myself, he developed algorithms
to interpret cancer genomes in real time,
enabling clinicians like me to deliver more
effective targeted therapies and advancing our understanding of
therapy resistance.
Eli's work has uncovered the integrated germline and somatic
mechanisms that drive oncogenesis,
identifying key genes, studying multiple diseases.
I don't know how he does it, melanoma, bladder cancer,
and a broad range of adult and even pediatric solid tumors.
He has developed novel computational methods that revealed previously
unrecognized patterns of somatic mutation
in the regulatory genomic regions.
Dr. Van Allen has made seminal contributions to defining genomic
underpinnings of lethal prostate cancer, which is really where I had
the privilege of working with Eli, and he really helped reshape the
landscape of our understanding of the genomics of prostate
cancer and its genomic investigation, and even
therapy development for this disease.
He currently integrates single-cell sequencing approaches to uncover new
mechanisms of treatment resistance and response and has really
been very involved, for example, in studying immunotherapy sensitivity and
resistance.
And in fact, I would say his research has identified tumor intrinsic
and immune microenvironment mechanisms that determine selective response to
immunotherapies across cancer types.
And he's developed innovative algorithms that integrate genomic,
histopathologic, and clinical data to guide AI-driven analysis
for patient care.
So collectively, Eli's work has advanced biomarker
discovery, helped develop precision medicine, and
expanded the role of computational biology and AI in
oncology.
Eli earned his medical degree from the David Geffen School of Medicine at
UCLA
and joined DFCI in 2010, where he trained as a
hematology oncology fellow before joining the faculty.
His achievements have been widely recognized.
A member of AACR since 2011, he was
one of the members of the AACR Team Science Award in 2020.
He's had a Mark Foundation Emerging Leader Award,
National Academy of Medicine Emerging Leader Award in 2023,
and the Trailblazer Prize from the Foundation for the NIH.
So please join me in welcoming the 2026 recipient
of the AACR Wang Ki Hong Award for Outstanding
Achievement for Translational and Clinical Research, Dr.
Van Allen. Congratulations.
Thank you, Johan. It's an overwhelming privilege and honor.
I'm sort of mortified and embarrassed by that, but I'm grateful
nonetheless. And
it's a privilege to be here to be able to share some of the work that we're doing
and that we have been doing in the context of this prestigious award.
And I'll save my remarks for Dr. Hong for the end of this presentation
on how that all ties together. But I thought I would start with
actually using this platform as an opportunity to share with you all my midlife
crisis in academics and how I have been and am thinking
about the science that we do, and how what we'd like to do going
forward, and this concept of molecular logic, which I'll explain in a moment.
There's our lab website and various social media handles in case anyone wants to
follow along. Here are my disclosures.But I thought I would also,
since there's a few, actually more than a few, friends in the audience that I
see, but there's some people who I don't know.
And so for those of you who haven't seen this, this is always a good opportunity to
reintroduce myself or introduce myself to you all.
You'll see in my equity disclosures that it says Microsoft.
I received five shares of Microsoft stock for my bar mitzvah in 1993,
and I have held onto that. So a good job by me and my parents for that one.
I went to college at Stanford. I studied something called symbolic systems,
which is effectively a computer science degree with a little bit of linguistics and
philosophy. And for those of you who might be familiar with that domain
or that part of the world at that time in the world,
you might think, "Surely, he will go off and go to tech
startups."
Part of the reason that ended up not happening was actually this course, called
First Order Logic, which maybe, I don't know if anyone in this room would have
ever taken for any reason, but it was easily the most
difficult and mind-bending experience I ever had in
science.
It's sort of a very, very aggressive math and logic-based course
that's required of this major. And so while all my friends sort of
sailed off into that world and then off into the world of tech, I
decided I needed to find something else to do, because this wasn't for me, at least
so I thought. As it happened, some friends had approached me to
say that they were starting a nonprofit, a camp for kids whose parents have cancer,
and they needed some help, and they needed some male counselors to chip in.
And so even though I had never been to a camp in my entire life up until that
point, I participated, helped to create this thing, had a life-changing
experience, and decided I needed to go into medicine generally, and cancer
medicine in particular. And so fast-forward some number of years later,
I found myself as a bit of an odd duck in academic medicine.
I was and am a clinician. I see patients every Monday morning in the prostate
cancer clinic at Dana-Farber.
I was and am a computer geek, sort of trying to make sense of first
order logic and other kinds of weird things that maybe the folks in this room don't
ever think about.
And I had become immersed in the world of oncology, and sort of the science and
biology as applied to that domain.
And so in this context, the patient is my model system.
I want to make algorithms to dissect and understand the high-dimensional data I
generate from my patients, and I want to immerse it in the world of biology as
applied to cancer. And it's that sweet spot in the middle is clinical
computational oncology, is the three words I kept saying over and over
again to try to justify my existence because there was nobody like me.
I couldn't point to anyone to say, "Yes, do what so-and-so wants to do." I had to
sort of carve it out for myself.
Conveniently for me, though, it was happening at around the time
that there was this explosion of the capacity to generate
large-scale molecular data directly in the clinic.
And so there's a version of a plot about all the different kinds of tests that we
were using and are using now that I'm going to put here and also come back to
a little bit later that tries to articulate the varying kinds of assays that we
were doing
based off of how much information or dimensionality there is.
And in this context, for most of my early training, I was right smack in the middle
of this plot. But this created an opportunity to create this field and
then pursue the science that I wanted to do.
But that itself wasn't sufficient because I was also wrestling with another
challenge in science.
During my postdoctoral research with Levi Garraway, I became immersed in some of
the work involving drug resistance, and specifically resistance to BRAF
mutant melanoma. And we had sort of started out with these canonical
signaling pathways that have these
three very specific genes. And what I learned through that process
was that the world was a lot more complicated than those three genes.
And the resistance mechanisms were exploding and hitting all these other genes and
various mutations and processes, and there was various combinations of them.
And it was just way too complicated for what this
paradigm was representing, this sort of reductionist paradigm.
Conversely, when I'd sort of wander into the world of systems biology, and
I'd look and try to make sense in my own mind of the outputs
that came out of those types of research paradigms, I struggled in a different way,
almost in the way as I was sitting in those first order logic classes, because
those were uninterpretable to me.
I couldn't figure out what to do with this practically as a clinician at the point
of care.
And so what I decided to do was see whether I could carve out some space in the
middle that occupied the journeys that my patients
were sort of experiencing in real-time.
They had their germline genomes, and they evolved, developed tumor
genomes, and those tumor genomes were interacting with the immune microenvironment,
and they were receiving therapies over time.
And I kind of stared at this a little bit longer,
and I started to realize that what I was doing may not have actually been that
far from those seemingly esoteric first order logic
classes as I thought they might be.
Because, for example, when I thought about one disease and I was thinking about the
different ways you can develop that disease and the genetics, and I would write
out these sentences. Well, you have a VHL mutate for kidney cancer, a VHL
mutation, germline or somatic, with a PBR1 mutation
or a BAP1 or SETT2, but not this other deletion, and so on and so forth.
Or tumor immune interactions. Well, you have these
certain tumor intrinsic programs that are up or down, these immune
microenvironmental ones that are up or down.
They interact with each other in certain ways.
Or in the context of resistance, you had developed resistance to a
hormone therapy in metastatic prostate cancer.
You might get MDM4 amplification or a p53 mutation with an
RB1 deletion sometimes, sometimes not.
And I stared at this for a bit and I said, "You know, this kind of reminds me of
something." This is actually no different in some sense than the
first order logic that I was taking years earlier, but instead of
esoteric math, this was actually biology and
genetics as applied to cancer.
And then I went back and actually dug up that textbook from
college, and I reopened up the first page of it, and that's probably as far as
I got because I didn't want to stress myself out too much.
But in the introduction, it actually summarized exactly what I thought I was going
for this whole time.Logic is articulating as elegantly as
possible the theory on which the subject matter rests.
And that is what I was trying to do and have been trying to do
in the world of precision medicine, in the world of computational oncology
for the first 10 plus years of our lab's existence, and what I wanted
to share with you all
over the next 20 to 25 minutes or so.
Because what we're trying to study is this molecular logic as applied
to cancer to see whether it can help us fill in the
gaps and understand more about precision cancer medicine.
There are three themes. One is a tumor-germline interaction domain,
one is a tumor immune microenvironmental domain, and one is a drug resistance
and progression to lethal disease domain.
So first, talk a little bit about tumor and germline interactions,
and what are the somatic and germline features that jointly contribute to
oncogenesis? What is the logic that combines all of these
different features together to create tumors, and
explain the evolution?
For this, the real challenge is actually filling in the gaps of what all
the features are in the first place.
You have to fill in the puzzle with all the different pieces that you might have
before you try to put it all together.
And this is something that I've been fascinated about since my first day as a
postdoctoral fellow in Levi's lab, when I saw one of my colleagues who at the
time was a grad student and is now a junior faculty member at Dana-Farber, Sylvan
Baca, along with Chris Barbieri over at Weill Cornell, presenting
this work, looking at about 100 prostate cancer exomes, applying
algorithms to their large-scale genomic data, and coming up with a list of genes
that they thought might explain a proportion of the
development of prostate cancer.
And we went from about 100 exomes to 1,000 exomes
in relatively short order in terms of time, and we were able to
expand that catalog of somatic mutations, in this case, in the coding
realm, that might explain or contribute to oncogenesis.
While we couldn't necessarily figure out all the puzzle pieces and
how they fit together in that research, we actually demonstrated how some of
them actually fit in some certain ways and started to fill in these gaps and
explain some of the logic puzzle of prostate cancer as one canonical
example. And in this case, in some sense, simply having more data ended
up filling in and helping us along the way.
But we also recognized that we had a lot of work to do because there was much more
to the world than somatic coding mutations.
And so what we've done ever since is try to fill in the gaps of other
kinds of pieces of puzzles that might explain the molecular
logic of cancer
development. So one example is actually looking into non-coding
somatic mutations, and this is work led by Felix Dietlein when he was a
postdoctoral fellow in my lab. He's now independent junior faculty at Children's
Hospital. Looking at, at the time, the largest set of somatic
cancer genomes that we can get our hands on,
he developed an entirely new algorithmic approach to understand and search
for and identify recurrent mutations, specifically in regulatory
regions. And we even took it a step further in nominating a
specific regions, in this case, in a region
near XPP1 in breast cancer, and actually functionally
testing and proving a bit about these non-coding
mutations. We didn't actually definitively explain how these cause
cancer because that was frankly something we realized very quickly that we weren't
even going to get close to doing. We could at least start to understand more
about the effect of some of these somatic non-coding mutations and their
impact on cancer genes writ large.
So if we have somatic coding mutations, somatic non-coding mutations,
which are still a work in progress and something that I hope and expect many people
in this room will help to fill in further and solve going forward.
We also don't want to forget about the germline, because surely, I'm sure
there's a few people in this room who I know from the mentorship they've given to
me, would get really mad if I didn't include the germline as part of this
search space for the logic of cancer development.
And here too, while I was lucky enough to start in the world of prostate cancer
as part of the PCF Stand Up to Cancer Dream Team, where I also got to meet Johan
and many other wonderful folks in this community, we were able to
contribute to some of the observations explaining some of the risk
for prostate cancer and the enrichment of BRCA2 mutations in advanced
prostate cancer populations, in this case, germline mutations
in BRCA2.
We then were able to extend this concept to a bunch of other contexts,
whether it was germ cell tumors in CHEK2, DNA repair genes writ
large in pediatric cancers, and time and again, we're
observing pathogenic coding mutations in the
germline genomes of patients that were enriched,
ultimately developing various kinds of solid tumors,
adult, pediatric, and so on and so forth.
And this is just a smattering of some of the examples, but the exciting thing for
us was that this helped to inform
which genes should be tested for in what capacity and so on and so forth.
But even this, we know, is not sufficient because there's many new
horizons to think about at this interface of germline and somatic
genomics and the logic that explains how they talk to each other in the
context of cancer development.
One brief example is in the setting of germline structural variants, and
this is an example of some work that came out of our lab within the last year or
so, looking for structural variants and their enrichment in
pediatric solid tumor populations.
And to our surprise, there's actually demonstrable evidence for the enrichment
in the inherited genomes of these patients, and
suggests that we should be searching for germline structural variants in
clinical settings, just as we look for coding mutations.
And it creates opportunities for new algorithms and new ways of thinking
about how we combine all of these complex germline features and all of these
complex somatic features in new ways to learn
more about how this logic fits together.I don't have the answers to all of it
today, certainly, and I'm sure there's many smart folks in this room who
are well ahead of the game in that regard.
But I think this is an area of profound excitement and innovation, and one that I
think is going to bear a lot of fruit going forward.
So much to be continued on this front, but wanted to at least give a sense of some
of the stuff we're thinking about in this part of the logic puzzle.
If the first part of our challenge is looking at the germline and somatic
genomes, how they interact, and what is the logic that might explain it, which I
don't think we've necessarily even come close to doing so far, but we still have a
lot of work to do there.
We now want to make it a little bit harder and think about how do
tumor and immune cells interact in the context of immunotherapy,
and what can we learn based off of the genomics of either the tumor
itself or features of the immune microenvironment in this context?
So this is another area that Ioan alluded to, is something we've been interested in
for a long time. We started out looking at
specifically tumor genomic features and their association with selective
response to immune checkpoint blockade.
In this case, revealing the sort of associations with tumor mutational burden
and neoantigens, which we know is a complex and still
uncertain path to various kinds of biomarker development for various reasons.
But I also point that out to say that was something that the community was
observing about 10 years ago. And the list of features that we
have since invoked as being relevant at this
tumor immune interface and explaining some of the logic that drives
selective immunotherapy responsiveness, has itself gotten a lot more
complicated and a lot harder to parse out.
So rather than try to go through all of them, I don't have the time to go through
them all, I thought I would zoom in on one example, one that's near and dear to my
heart, both in good and bad ways, and try to explain where the field is
at and where there are opportunities for further discoveries.
And this is in the context, specifically, of looking at selective immunotherapy
responsiveness in kidney cancer and chromatin genes.
So as with other cancer types, sort of rewind a little bit, we
were interested in understanding why some kidney tumors were immunoresponsive and
others weren't.
We were lucky to get our hands on an early cohort of trial patients who had
received immune checkpoint blockade.
And obviously, as you can tell by this plot, there was not an overwhelming amount
of data that we were able to work with.
But we did our best and tried to make sense of it.
The first thing we did was look for whether there was any association with
mutational burden, and not surprisingly, because kidney cancer doesn't really
have such a thing as high mutational load disease outside of
extremely rare MSI kidney cancers.
We didn't see any association in this context, and so we had to keep searching.
And so led by Diana Miao and Claire Margolis, picture below, they actually zoomed
in on reframing the question around genes
that we know are enriched to be mutated into kidney cancer and
re-asking the question about whether any of them segregate by clinical
response. And in this context, they were able to recover loss of function
mutations in a gene called PBRM1, which is a chromatin
modifier, and demonstrate that the folks who had
mutations in this gene had
very distinct clinical outcomes to immune checkpoint blockade than those who
didn't.
Sort of notably, when we did a post hoc meta-analysis of our entire cohort
in this original study, which is now a bit on the older side, we observed that the
signals seemed to be coming from patients who were receiving immune checkpoint
blockade, mostly not in the first-line setting, so they had already
received some kind of VEGF-TKI of some sort or another.
We noted it. We weren't sure what to make of it, but we thought it was interesting
nonetheless.
Lucky for us, and this is sort of a thing that I learned as part of this journey as
a junior faculty member,
there were other folks interested in asking the same question, although on the
mechanistic side. And I say that because when we first made
this observation, years before we actually published it, we shared it
in an internal meeting at the Broad, with a little bit of trepidation, because it
was a bit half-baked. We didn't know what we were looking for.
We weren't sure how good it was going to be.
But a lot of folks reached out to us immediately afterwards.
Kai Wupperfing and his group actually had recovered the same genes as
coming up in a screen, looking for genes that when mutated or knocked
out, conferred T-cell-mediated cytotoxicity in melanoma.
So there were some mechanistic suggestions there.
Bill Kaelin was kind enough to share some of his data that we can investigate for
this specific question. And Dave Barby actually had independently recovered an
association looking at loss of function of these specific
genes and increase in endogenous retroviruses.
And I bring this up because this is something we've continued to pursue and
explore in terms of trying to explain the rationale for why this is happening,
and what the underlying biology is that explains this particular
property. And indeed, we've continued to expand
our cohort sizes to dissect these relationships further and
even pursue some experimental work.
This is soon-to-be-published data looking at
knocking out PBRM1 in cell lines and trying to see whether that results in
specific increases in some ERVs or endogenous retroviruses that
are known to be enriched in this immun responsive setting.
And so this is still a work in progress as well, but of course, the real question
is whether this externally replicates in any clinical cohort.
So our first chance at asking this question was in a randomized clinical trial
setting, Checkpoint 025. So these were patients that mimicked, reasonably
so, the discovery cohort that we started out with.
These were patients who received VEGF-TKIs. They progressed.
They then were randomized to getting immune checkpoint blockade or
the other second-line standard of care, everolimus.
And so indeed, we were able to recover a consistent signal, although
not nearly as strong as in our discovery cohort, of loss of function
mutations in this gene
and selective response. And interestingly, this was only observed in the
nivolumab arm. We didn't see it in the everolimus arm. So this was interesting.
And I should also add, we're actually kind of surprised or curious to see that in a
much more recent study of a combination strategy
of VEGF-TKI plus pembrolizumab, so a different immune
checkpoint blockade to a degree, and a different TKI.
Actually, the authors independently recovered this association in a very
recent report, looking at
whether PBRM1 mutations segregated.
And there's other data in that regard that seem to suggest this as well.
And so you might be thinking, "Well, that's great, Eli, but that's weird.
I don't hear everyone testing this gene in the clinic.
So what's the deal?"And the reality is
that
logic is complicated. And what we thought we were observing
seemed to hold in multiple cohorts, but it didn't hold in all of them.
And we had to be very honest and transparent about that uncertainty of what we were
observing, and that in some cases, the mechanistic work helped to
explain this curiosity. So there was work by others demonstrating,
including Bill Kaelin recently, that these ERVs
in a PBRM1 mutant setting are
HIF-dependent, which means they're almost like, in mechanistic models, mimicking
the clinical scenario that we tended to observe this association in most strongly.
And that clinical context is no longer relevant
because patients aren't getting these drugs serially.
They're getting them in combination. They're getting them in parallel.
And so all of that work told us that the logic we were looking for
wasn't considering the real-time clinical scenarios we needed them to,
and we were only measuring one part of the puzzle.
We weren't even thinking about the immune microenvironment in that context.
And so we wanted to think about some other ways we could do that to help fill in
this part of the puzzle as well.
And so for this, I'm actually going to return back to this plot, and instead of
thinking about some of the molecular assays that we had spent most of the time
talking about to date, which are things right in the middle here, I'm going to zoom
back down to the bottom right of this plot and talk about some of the work we ended
up doing to investigate this further using H&Es
and computational pathology. And so
H&Es obviously are much more ubiquitous in the clinic, and conceivably
could produce scalable,
human interpretable features that might help us ask these kinds of questions in a
grander way.
But they come with their own challenges because what we'd like to do is
actually build computational pathology models that are interpretable, that are not
black boxes, that represent the biology that we think is most relevant
in this context. And so one of my students at the time, Jackson Nyman, pictured
below,
took that question head on. And basically, instead of thinking about
brute force AI for making predictions without any
ability to understand the why of the puzzle, he
built what he called more biologically grounded deep learning, an
opaque box that actually builds AI layer by
layer, such that each layer is
interpretable to humans and in combination, could help us
understand what some of their features are, some of those puzzle pieces that we
need for this logic puzzle that actually explain
a response to immunotherapy. And so that could still seem a little abstract and
years later, I still struggle to explain that in totality.
Sometimes a picture is worth a thousand words. So let me just show you what I mean.
So here's an H&E from a kidney cancer. There it is.
Here was the first layer of the AI model, so it's relatively straightforward, tumor
versus not tumor prediction with a map.
Then what we did was train models to look for grade.
And here you can take something that is actually human
interpretable and is done by humans all the time, but it is not done by
humans pixel by pixel. So no human is going to spend the time to
create a nuclear-grade topology like I'm depicting below, but
computers can do this with ease.
And what we noticed when we started to do that was that some of these tumors had
heterogeneity in their grade in a way that was
quantifiable and visualized, but had not been appreciated.
And we could actually take these types of AI and convert
what is a typically subjective feature into a quantifiable and
quantitative feature,
and basically measure in
totality how much heterogeneity there is in the
tumor. Incidentally, that property of
heterogeneity associated with some of the genomic features that we had previously
recovered in this context with PBRM1.
And then on top of that, we could add additional models that look at the immune
cells in the microenvironments that are also interpretable and improving in
real-time.
And in totality, take
puzzle pieces involving tumor cells and puzzle pieces involving the immune
microenvironment, combine them together into human interpretable
features and quantify which of those patients ended
up responding or not responding to immunotherapy.
And we can do a much better job of stratifying our patients in the same
Checkpoint 025 using this interpretable computational
pathology approach than we had using a single genomic feature from the
tumor
as I showed previously. And so this, to us, gave us some initial
clues that perhaps there was ways to revisit old
datasets,
convert them into high-dimensional pieces of information, but then still
make them biologically interpretable.
Because, again, we are clinical computational oncologists.
We want to understand the biology that might be at play here, and we
want to be able to use these kinds of data to invoke and pursue
additional hypotheses based off of what we see.
But that's not all in this context, and this is a space that's continuing to evolve
rapidly and is very exciting to see where it's going, because I can also say
in addition to doing everything in the middle of this plot and on the bottom right
of this plot, we certainly are also keen to explore
the high-dimensional data that you can generate using single-cell and
spatial platforms, increasingly being applied into a variety of clinical
settings by many folks in this room, certainly, and also by us.
And not just apply them in singleton form such that you apply it to one
dataset, you make some inference, and then you move on.
But also, just as we had done in the prostate cancer domain much earlier, that I
described earlier, where we were combining large sets of data,
and the more we combined, the more we could learn, we could actually do the
same thing with single-cell multi-omic datasets as well.
And so this is an example led by Kevin Bee, a computational
biologist in the lab, where he took...
multiple published cohorts of kidney cancer single-cell data, including
ours, figured out how to harmonize them, which is non-trivial to say the
least, and then link them to a variety of clinical
properties,
and zooming in on a variety of cell type specific properties that I don't have time
to go into,
recovering a myeloid specific signature that
vastly improved our ability to explain the phenotypes
of immuno-responsiveness than we had done previously.
And this is just an example to illustrate the point.
The last thing I'll say on this part of the logic puzzle is that this was a deep
dive into one very specific set of features in one specific
solid tumor, but these opportunities abound.
And one of the most exciting things that, for me, over the last few years, has been
applying these kinds of strategies across a wide variety of cancer
types and making all sorts of surprising discoveries.
And this is just a sneak peek of one example led by another one of my
oncology fellows, Dr. Erica Pimenta, in liposarcomas.
Here, trying to define the well-differentiated, on the bottom, or
dedifferentiated parts of a liposarcoma that's on the top,
whereby she recovered not only tumor intrinsic properties that explain
that lineage plasticity, that shape-shifting, involving things
like PPARy and GLP-1 biology on the tumor side, but
also invoking some very interesting features about myeloid cells in the immune
microenvironment. And again, there's many other examples like this, but I just want
to give you a flavor of where we are and where we think we can
go in this space to fill out this part of the puzzle.
So if we started with oncogenesis and tumor origins in the context
of tumor and germline interactions, we move to tumor and immune
interactions. The last part of this, of course, would be studying tumors over
time in the context of therapy resistance.
And here, to understand this logic, I'll actually go back to the prostate cancer
study I started out with,
and revisit one last part of it that we took a crack
at.
One part of that cohort sort of nuance was that it was split between
primary or indolent prostate cancers and metastatic or lethal
prostate cancers. And we, at that time, back in 2018,
looked for and searched for genes that were segregating or
associated with, that when mutated rather, were associated with one
clinical state or another. We recovered TP10,
p53, and AR, which was reassuring because those
are things that the field knows, but we couldn't really make sense of a
lot of the stuff in this part of the box.
And that begged us to wonder whether there were other ways to represent this kind
of data and these kinds of patient journeys over time, and whether there were new
models that we could pursue,
to actually help ask and answer that question.
And so for this, we again, in the spirit of trying to make biologically
informed models, in this case using artificial intelligence,
built something called Peanut. This was led by Haytham Elmarakeby, pictured below.
And the idea here is that one inputs into such a model, all
of the molecular features that you have,
and you feed it into a neural net. But instead of a generic neural net, it's
one that is pre-engineered to represent the biology
that we know exists, that has already been worked out and
represented through a variety of resources.
And the key with that kind of an approach is that you could train it on such a
question, like primary versus lethal prostate cancer, and it can produce a
very well-performing model. It will do a good job clinically.
But it's also completely interpretable.
You can open the black box
and look at and inspect every part of the network to
understand why the algorithm is making that prediction, just like
in the H&E computational pathology space, we can start to understand why and use
it to ask and answer more questions.
And so we did that in that context. We actually found an unexpected
association with MDM4, which then resulted in some additional validation,
both experimentally and clinically, that we're now trying to seek out, actually,
biotech partners for therapeutic pursuits.
But it's 2026, and I can't end with a
CNN kind of an algorithm. We've got to say, we can do a lot better, and there's a
lot of other cool stuff that we can think about going forward.
And so some of the things that are works in progress that, again, I don't have time
to go into, but are things that I'm excited about and I wanted to share with you
all in the space of translational research, are the use of single-cell
foundation models,
better deep learning architectures, graph neural nets, and so on and so forth, and
maybe some of the craziest things we're doing these days, using agentic AI
to actually effectively replace a lot of the work that we do and/or
pursue scientific reasoning in ways that we never would have imagined doing.
So the last part of this is really around bringing this logic and these
concepts into the clinic, because again, this is not just about
abstract science or translational research on its own.
This is about the clinic and how do we do that.
I don't have time to go into the details, but one of the things we've been slaving
over for many years is this idea of coalescing all these
kinds of information, all of these kinds of knowledge and learning into open
source algorithms that can be deployed at the point of care through
something called the Molecular Oncology Almanac, led by Brendan Reardon, pictured
below. This is a comically open sourced
type of method. We have websites, APIs, portals. You can upload your information.
We'll never touch it, and so on and so forth.
And we've been starting to pursue this idea of globally informed precision
oncology. So one of the challenges to these kinds of approaches has been that
we'll typically be able to include information about FDA approvals, but
our friends from other parts of the world are like, "Well, that's nice, but I don't
live there, and so help me come up with a better way to do this." And so we've been
working with a variety of collaborators, whether in the US or in
other countries around the world,
to integrate all of that parts of knowledge into a
completely holistic version of precision oncology and
delivering as much of it as we can in as thoughtful and globally
informed way as we can. This is just one part of the innovations we're doing.
Much more to come, but we're pretty jazzed about that as well.And
so that's where I'd like to sort of pivot for the last couple of minutes to Dr.
Hong,
who I personally did not have the privilege of knowing, although he left such a
remarkable legacy that it's impossible not to sort of feel like you know him, even
if you don't.
And one of the most remarkable things he did towards the end of his
career was the BATTLE study, which was so remarkably ahead of
its time. And it's amazing to me. This is actually, it was in
issue one of "Cancer Discovery," I believe, is where this came from, this
schema and these results. And I looked at this trial and I was like, "Wow,"
this already had been conceived, executed, published before I
even started my postdoc. And I'm looking at it and like, this is basically
what we're still all trying to do today.
And I just thought that was remarkable.
And that's the spirit of what we're trying to channel going forward in the space of
precision oncology, or at least I hoped I left you with today.
But that's not all. The more I read about him, the more I was struck
by these kinds of comments.
His ability to organize team science was unparalleled.
He continuously articulated the importance of working together to
accomplish ambitious and impactful science with the end goal of benefiting
patients. Nobody was more passionate about mentoring young
talent.
And that also struck with me because that's something that I've really sort
of been very grateful to
experience myself. I've had a few folks in the lab who've been with me since
day one. Dr. Jihae Park, who's here, Brendan Riordan, who's I believe
not here today,
who I've had a chance to work with, along with
a very large set of remarkable humans that I
either currently work with or have previously worked with.
We had a great 10-year anniversary party last year sort of
celebrating the past, present, and future of this ecosystem.
And sort of seeing it actually play out in real life has been truly the joy
of my professional career.
And of course, I didn't get here by accident.
I actually only got here mostly because Levi sat me down on my first day as a
postdoc and said, "Listen, we're going to give you a bunch of genomic data, and
you've got to figure out how to make this useful in the clinic." And I didn't
understand most of the words that were coming out of Levi's mouth at the time,
but I'm very grateful that he took me on regardless.
And of course, it was with him and many others who I've had the privilege
of counting on as mentors. Here's some folks locally in Boston, but there's
actually many others, including many folks in this room who I'd want to acknowledge
as well.
And
the last thing I'll say is that, and this is maybe perhaps the most important part,
and always why it's so wonderful to come to these meetings and to
see so many friendly faces, hopefully meet some new faces, is to remind ourselves
of the real point of this.
And I think this is sort of one last quote in a bunch of the reading I did with Dr.
Hong of like, he's using terms around baseball, some of it was sort of more
career development. "Don't always try to hit a home run, just go for a small hit."
But, he also was asking people to study hard, working for 18 hours a day
as he did,
because the winning runner is still on base, and we still have so much work to do.
And that's, I think, the part that keeps me going and makes me so excited
about where this space is going. And so with that, thank you all again.
Thanks to all the folks in the lab I get to work with. Thank you for coming.
And I also give a special thanks to my wife who's dealing with those two
out on the East Coast while I get to be out here to tell you all about this
science. So thank you again.
So there's some questions.
Have you examined whether evolutionary constraint may explain the link
between germline predisposition and somatic progression?
This is a great question. I think we've tried or started to try.
I think we're still a little underpowered probably to sort of
address that in totality. There's some opportunities now with various biobank-level
datasets that have both germline and somatic genomes, which probably would be
required to answer that question in full, but
it's a great one that I think it's an exciting area to explore.
Eli, thank you. Great talk.
And congrats for this well-deserved award.
I want to take you back to your introduction.
In some perspective, this novel AI agentic
tools are on the other side of the scale from the first-order logic.
In your philosophical perspective,
what is the interface? Is AI just a complex aggregation of
first-order logics that we're trying to interpret and will succeed,
or it's some higher-order logic that we are just taking the low-hanging fruits?
That's a great question. I kind of left it ambiguous on purpose, but
thank you for calling it out regardless.
I would expect you of all people definitely would do it.
I mean that in a good way. That was a compliment.
The honest answer, I'm not sure.
But I think
even with the agentic AI platforms and all that work, and we have some
stuff we're cooking up that will hopefully get out soon, I think others do as well.
It is still upon us to make sure that what is produced is
still interpretable. Because there's, if nothing else, going to
be major trust issues if we just
go for the agentic AI, and it's throwing out whatever
principles of God knows what is actually in there that's actually helping it to
make these predictions.
We've already seen examples where that actually goes awry.
And I think
pressuring the community to ensure that we're still thinking carefully about
why these
technologies are making the predictions they are or taking the
actions that they are, I think is actually critical.
Because anecdotally, what we've seen is that for every
time that it seems like it's pursuing something either correctly
or even thoughtfully in a way that I might not have thought of, it's doing
something crazy. And if we didn't look under the hood to understand what all the
steps were,
we would be doing something very bad.
And I think there's lots of examples like that in the field that I think still...
require us to consider interpretability and understanding
when we're using these models.
Yes. Thank you for a wonderful talk. I'm Jack Lee from MD Anderson.
I had the fortune to work with Dr. Hang for the past
30 years. And actually, Dr. Hang's son, Burt, and his
family are here.
Yeah.
And really, I'm also very grateful for Dr.
Hang for what he has done for the field, and also he was my
mentor as well. But I want to ask a question, I think
about
how to
input, how to use the biology or
the accumulated,
either
biological or clinical information into forming the
foundation model as you mentioned.
Because right now, many of the foundation model, they
use purely AI tools and purely
the data without
putting really the biology there and the clinical
information there. You mentioned about that.
Yes.
Can you say a bit more about how to do that?
Oh, yeah. So it's a great question, and it's a really hard one.
So in our works from a few years ago, the way we engineered biology into the
network was we took the Reactome database, which has
logic built into it about genes connected to signaling pathways, and then
signaling pathways connected into programs and modules and so on and so forth.
And that's what makes it interpretable.
It's actually, in some sense, a very problematic approach because if those of you
who play with the Reactome database know, it's both incomplete.
It's only about 4,000 or 5,000 genes out of 20,000. It's also wrong.
I think if you were, let's say, pick out somebody who's an expert in DNA repair and
have them look at the DNA repair module of Reactome, they'll find things to quibble
with. And so there's
incorrectness there. And so the foundation model folks say, "Yes, that's why we
should just go off of just first principles and brute force learn this and not
worry about it." But that's also problematic because,
one, there's lots of issues there, but not the least of which is, is they're
treating biology like it's language.
They're using, effectively, a lot of these kinds of methods that were
built for language models, and taking a
cell and sorting it by genes and their expression, high to low, and
making a sentence out of that. Which is,
I don't think folks in this room would necessarily think that makes any sense.
And that's actually just step one of a very big process.
And so the hope is that there's going to be some way to find a middle
ground between those two approaches.
Some of that may actually be using some of these agentic strategies that
have in their pre-training, a representation of all prior
scientific literature or knowledge of those kinds of things.
But that also won't be sufficient.
That's why we still need to be able, as for the prior question, need to be able to
pick apart at the reasoning and the logic that the AI actually uses and
ask ourselves whether that's correct.
So it's an evolving and challenging
space. And you hit the nail on the head, and it's actually, I think the hardest
part of this whole problem right now and why a lot of the foundation models, at
least in single-cell, are still lacking in the way that we would hope they would be
useful.
Ellie, can I ask you a question?
Yeah.
I've been at several really outstanding sessions of this meeting on
AI,
some of which I don't really understand.
But one of my concerns is that
a lot of the published data we know is incorrect.
In fact, probably the preponderance of data.
Maybe not entirely incorrect, but quite a lot of it is incorrect.
So how do we work together as a community to curate data and
maybe weight data based on their validity?
Yeah, that's a very hard question because it's effectively impossible to
scale
weighting. And then even then it's like, well, who's weighting? Is it us humans?
We have our own biases that we bring to the table.
Can AI do that? Can AI weight the data?
Yeah. There's always different ways to weight these things.
Yeah.
But you bring actually to the forefront one of the biggest challenges to the
folks who are claiming that agentic AI knows everything already.
You
hit it. We know that a lot of the scientific literature is
wrong or gets corrected or has all sorts of issues or is missing
bits and pieces.
But on the flip side, we can't all just
quit our jobs and spend the next 10 years, 100 years trying to curate all the
knowledge.
Some middle ground is probably the
safe bet where we
use but don't trust these tools unless everything gets replicated or
validated or confirmed in some way, shape, or form.
We've done an example of this looking actually at CRISPR screening data, and
trying to assess the power of agentic
reasoning for figuring out without knowing what the CRISPR screening
hits are. And we've observed that it will overweight certain
kinds of evidence that are probably incorrect, and I think brings its own biases.
And I think maybe the most provocative thing would be to say, well,
it brings its own biases and we bring our own biases.
They're probably non-overlapping, and maybe the best strategy
forward is to take both bits together somehow.
But I think that's also just happening in real time.
I don't think we know the right way to do it.
Thank you. We have one more question. I think that'll be the last one. Thank you.
Okay.
I'm Dong Shin from Emory University.
I also working with Qui Hong for many years when I was in MD Anderson
Cancer Center. But anyhow, my question to you,
so we have specific gene positive, let's say
non-small cell lung cancer, we have RET gene positive, and then we have a
specific target agents. So if you apply
the AI in that situation-Can you
kind of subset analysis whether
certain AI is a positive one and negative one is more
specifically
response to a specific target agents?
So I think AI could be advantage for that thing, but I'm
not sure. So you can-
So if I understood you correctly, I think maybe what you're asking is,
could you take a base AI model and augment it with
things that we know are true to help it along the way?
Is that what you meant, or?
Yeah. So I think if you have a specific gene positive,
then if you apply to the AI, whether you have a further subset
analysis because of the specific target agent
is not responding all, right? So some of them further responded or not
responded, can you help by the AI?
So I think we think so. I think the
challenge there is usually the data and volume.
And in some cases, if the datasets are small, you may not need
AI to even
ask that question. In fact, in many cases, you probably don't need AI to ask that
question directly.
But the other part of the question about can you then, if you knew something about
those gene relationships, could you augment AI
to have it know where to look for those kinds of answers more
readily? That's actually something we and others have been pursuing.
We had a recent report on this. It's called RAG.
There's a CS term that it relates to.
Basically, how do you effectively help AI do its job better in
niche or constantly evolving scenarios?
And it actually works. It's not surprising. If you help it, it works.
But even there, it's not perfect. And so in that study, just as a brief
anecdote, we started to observe that it was so aggressively
trying to please us that when we would ask it questions about instances where there
is no FDA approval or there is no relationship between gene and drug,
it would start to hallucinate one or make one up in some way, shape, or form
because it wanted to give us an answer.
And so we actually had to enforce rules to basically tell it that
if there is none, you have to return that there is none.
You are not allowed to make things up.
And so that's where the current state of AI is in this space, which I think may
mimic how people perhaps experience AI in their day-to-day
lives
outside of science or medicine. I'll end with an anecdote about
my daughter. We made a cookbook together using Claude.
I shouldn't mention companies, but whatever.
And she wanted
smoked salmon in her dish, and it asked her if she wanted it cool, and she said,
"No, I want it warm." She's nine.
And
it didn't say warm smoked salmon. That's weird.
It said, "What a whimsical take on a traditional dish.
That sounds amazing." And I think that's the fear is that kind of
AI pervades into medicine and research and
as per a lot of the questions, and that's where we'll all be in trouble.
Yeah.
That's all.
Great talk. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you, Eli. Thank you to Dr. Ki Hong's family.
His
memory and impact continues today. And Eli, congratulations.
Thank you, everybody.